welcome to another episode of the Jenna
and Jillian pod can you [ __ ] yeah your
legs so the purpose of our podcast in
case you didn't watch our other [ __ ]
first episode where we had a billion
technical difficulties is that we used
to sit around and get drunk all the time
on Ustream and our Ustream friends we're
like why don't you make this a podcast
so that we oh my god so that we can
watch this or listen to this when we're
not at like watching it like 3:00 in the
morning so yes so we wanted to record
not to make anything other than you
streaming on a different camera and with
microphones and fancy hat hopefully they
don't cry crash this time but we think
we have a solid setup all right yeah so
we asked our friends on Ustream what we
should talk about and they said Julian's
lifting competition where he did an
Olympic weightlifting competition he
competed at 85 kilos yep and the young
Hollywood Awards which we attended on
Sunday night
the viral superstar away yeah comics I
don't know when we're gonna air this
podcast episode but this past Sunday's
when we did that yeah and also Julian's
new puppy named peach that is right so I
think that's what we're gonna be talking
about yeah yeah we get us you know we
got a solid lineup of things to start
off at least and then whoever you know
who knows where that's gonna go that's
the kind of the whole idea if it takes
us into a different conversation then
we'll go there that's what we do yeah
beep ah boo boo boo boo beep white wine
Viva Viva beep white wine tangents um I
want to start it off with the young
Hollywood Awards because personally I
think that well okay for those of you
know what happened you can kind of tune
out but basically for those who don't
Jenna I was invited to this award show
called the young Hollywood Awards which
if you were there or if you're watching
on TV it looked just as nice and
official as any other award show you'd
be watching I mean it's not the Oscars
there's not everyone there like that
it's a whole different crowd but it is
an award show and it is an award show
based in mainstream media so everyone
there had been in movies or TV or yeah
they're actors and
yeah yeah so people know their name I
mean there is not like uh internet
internet people there there was Jana
there was Jenna and felt like a fish out
of water
well there was Jenna and Tyler Oakley
and it was you two I mean there were a
couple other nominees um but what was
really cool is that they had this award
at all it was called the viral superstar
award and it was basically acknowledging
the online presence right
you know a fraction of what makes up you
know people who have fan bases and an
entertainment and stuff like that and
Jenna was nominated as she won and Brian
he does line Hagar's cena grammy bethany
mota Tyler Oakley and Tyler was know
Tyler was the only one there right yeah
and Ryan we talked to Ryan Ryan said he
wasn't even [ __ ] invited yeah Mike
Ryan please like come over like let's
hang out right once I realize right um
yeah Oh [ __ ]
damn which is odd because I feel like
well but I feel like a lot of the we'll
get back to what we're saying but I feel
like a lot of the nominees who didn't
win weren't about weren't there right
well that's half a thing with some of
these award shows they will give an
award to actors and actresses especially
high-profile ones yeah to the ones that
are able to show up well cuz you can't
just be giving awards to people that
aren't they sure it doesn't look like
there's no reason like nothing against
claw wasn't named Chloe grace Moretz or
whatever but she's in a category with
like Jennifer Lawrence for like best
female actress and Chloe wins and you're
like alright yeah maybe but it's pretty
sure if the electric Jennifer Lawrence
were here this would be considered an
upset yes yeah I'm saying yeah so I feel
like in order it's that's why the
business sort of politic II aspect of it
where it's like you can't really give
all these awards to people that aren't
gonna show up yeah no no that makes all
the sense it's just you and you notice
it yeah it makes it makes sense although
I'd really really don't understand why
like you wouldn't just invite the
internet people cuz you know that will
show up oh you'll show up you'll make a
video about like it's just even not Ryan
he lives in Vegas if if they were giving
him an award or they invite him I'm sure
he would have made the effort or at
least looked into his schedule but it
supposed to come in yeah
regardless um see you Ryan what was cool
is that yeah you know she was
representing the Internet really well
she came out she looked hot as hell
she's wearing her who dress Lina rah
mama I found her by the way
those of you that don't know who that is
I'm cutting you off I don't care because
I love Lina so much
I asked you I found her on Instagram uh
you know because I have an obsession
with falling hot girls on Instagram and
I found her and I was like who the [ __ ]
is this hot-ass [ __ ] and why are you
wearing somebody dumped clothes and then
I realized that she needed the clothes
and I fouled her forever and I've been
I've been meaning to email her being or
like order some things from her just in
general but because she makes them like
herself it takes you know a few weeks to
make them and like this kinda came up
last minute where I wouldn't have an
opportunity to actually order a piece
from her and they're not like in terms
of like a dress or something nice to
wear they're like in the hundred to two
hundred dollar range they're not like a
manageable right it's not a radius Lea
expensable
except expensive especially since we
went to the mall and if you go to like a
Macy's or Bloomingdale's like you're
hard-pressed to find like an evening
dress for under a hundred [ __ ]
dollars so it's relatively reasonable
and she's so [ __ ] hot and she just
was like yeah I'll make you a gown no
problem it turned out dude it turned out
really nice it was a great color I fit
you awesome oh thank you yeah
Lina's Lane is really cool I met her too
when we picked it up it's really awesome
that Jenna got prettiest human Jenna's
got a big girl crush Halloween I got any
one but you know you came you came
dressed you know done up to the nines
and he took the award and not you know
you could there was a lot of acceptance
speeches like every single award show
where they kind of go on about
themselves in their career and their
team which isn't a bad thing because you
know you got an award so it is your
moment but Jenna did get up there and in
my opinion she did the best job that she
could of sharing what she had just been
given in terms of the honor and the
attention and everything that they were
giving her with with all of her
colleagues you know all the youtubers
that she knows and all the youtubers
that exist and basically everyone else
that's made the internet what it is
today and I thought it was I was just a
really extraordinary thing to be there
watching that
an award show where you know these award
show has been going on forever like
these have are are as old as
entertainment themselves well at least
for a young Hollywood Awards I think it
was like their 14th that's a big that's
I mean that's not that's Nijo award show
and but but they just like the whole
thing it just seemed really cool to see
the internet thing immersed in such an
old-school and kind of classic award
show and she did a great job she had a
great speech her earring fell out right
as she got up to the mic which I thought
was hilarious but she caught it like a
champ but yeah you know if you're Ryan
Higa or if you're any other youtuber in
the entire world and you're watching
that feature like yeah you know that's
really awesome I don't even know if I
would have done that but she represented
the internet really well she shouted out
she said this is really a team effort I
feel like it's a special thing that I'm
accepting this but it's really kind of
our whole Awards and each you know she
complimented Tyler and then she left and
I really liked it I thought it was a
good job yeah thanks I mean the main
point I was trying to make although I
like to think that I keep myself
composed under high-pressure situations
but this was sort of like you know that
it's gonna be televised you know you
can't swear you know that there's a
bunch of like actors and people that
like I look up to that I think are
really cool in the audience like they're
sitting right [ __ ] in front of you
like Janet Ebert
yeah no big deal busy three million
follower but um so you know you get up
there and of course I had to walk all
the way to the back of that [ __ ]
stage and those heels and my dress and
I'm like vagina and boobies everywhere
like just hoping and praying they don't
fall down and I sort of had in my mind
that I didn't although like I think what
I do is cool but there's plenty people
that have been doing it for much longer
than me much better than I do
it's the fact that I'm sort of being
acknowledged was amazing but I felt like
it was beyond me do you mean because we
sort of we stick together in terms of
being youtubers or new media or any way
that you frame that and it felt you know
as much as anyone would love to an
accept an award and be like I love my
family
and my friends and everyone whatever it
didn't feel right it felt more
appropriate to be like I would like to
you know share this in a way that's like
I didn't get here by myself this is sort
of been everyone's collective effort to
create and make online media what it is
now um and I sort of [ __ ] got so
nervous when I got up there and I like
spit some of it out I would have liked
to have said just like a couple more
things that made it more so it you know
got home the message that I was trying
to say that like I'm physically
accepting it but it's really like we did
this together and it's an accomplishment
for all of us that we're even being
recognized on this scale and uh yeah I
[ __ ] blacked out man that [ __ ] was
terrifying
it was legitimately terrified a lot a
lot of people they're full theater like
almost what almost 2,000 people yeah and
you know my earring just commit suicide
it jumped right out of my ears soon as I
get up there of course and I'm like oh
god I'm stretch it I don't know what to
do like and this is why we can't have
nice things
nice I think yeah you know you weren't
just another actor which is why I think
it backs up the claim that you shouldn't
have just talked about you right I can't
just say oh you're thanks I did all of
this by myself because I really did it
yeah yeah and also you're in a situation
where you're a pioneer like you're one
of the first to do what is now being
recognized one of the first not the
first but you are kind of paving the way
along with a handful of other people so
there's a ward it's nothing regular you
know I mean it hasn't been happening
right well yes accept it like that well
recognition has not been happening and I
feel like it's appropriate to be like if
someone else got up there and accepted
the award and was like I'm so in love
with myself and I do such great things I
would sort of be like you know we kind
of all worked on this together dick yeah
yes it is a good way that you handled it
well because it's sort of like naive of
me to think like oh what I did sort of
is just so wonderful yeah that it
surpassed anyone elses when in reality
like we work together as a community to
create
a space that is you know really kick-ass
and like it needs to be a collective
sort of thing at least for you know the
time being in the foreseeable like near
future yeah this is not an individual
effort it's a group team effort that we
are working on yeah to be you know taken
seriously as content creators yeah do
you know yeah and it was a short speech
but I think you you got you hit that
point that was the only thing I didn't I
didn't want to stand up there like
oh here comes some Internet trash
thinking she's hot [ __ ] [ __ ] like I
really wanted to keep it short and sweet
and then get the [ __ ] out of there yeah
yeah before people are like boo get off
you look like a hooker
you did great thank you it was a good um
yeah so that was the young Hollywood
Awards uh the name of the award was
viral superstar uh and Jenna won that
the red carpet was [ __ ] yeah I've
never done a red carpet before and I
hated most of it oh yeah I wasn't big on
that that was that was a scary thing
yeah yeah you wait in line forever and
ever and ever and oh my god do we have
to do this like you know I've never been
to a word show or anything like that
like any reasonable person is just like
what the [ __ ] like what do we do I don't
even know what we're waiting in line for
oh I guess we're going up there and just
sort of a [ __ ] formality that you go
and get your picture taken that you've
gotten there or whatever so there's a
billion photographers and people video
cameras lined up on one side and on the
other side is where you sort of stand
which is the red carpet or blue carpet
in this case and you are allowed to go
with the people that you came with so I
went with Rome and Julian and waiting in
line you know we get cut by every
celebrity ever that needs to get into
the award show presenters [ __ ]
whoever and then a lot this just took a
lot of ego that goes with it that's like
oh this person needs to cut the entire
line so that they can get in because
they're really important in and we were
just standing I forget what her name was
the one that came out on behalf of
variety latina and she turned to me her
publicist had you know cut us and like
put we've been lady waiting in line for
like a [ __ ] half an hour not that it
really [ __ ] me
because I was no rush to get up in there
but she turned to me and she was like oh
I'm really really sorry about this and I
was like I don't [ __ ] worry about it
like [ __ ] knock yourself out go right
out there my boo legs I'm not in a rush
to go up there yeah why he turn you down
cuz it's hot that's Ari
oh um yeah anyways it was just it's
[ __ ] and politic E and ego stroking
and then once we got up there everyone
kept yelling at Julianne to get off I
was in the way of everyone's picture
it's a small space because there's a lot
of people on the red carpet so you only
have so much room to stand when you're
not in a picture so I was either inching
in in Jenna's picture or inching in to
the person next to hers picture yeah but
it was very very aggressive the way
those photographers talk they're very
aggressive they're loud it's not
friendly at all they're not friendly
they gotta get their shot and they gotta
get the hell out of there well it's a
business that's their livelihood you
know I take it to Jersey to take it
seriously it doesn't hurt to be nice
yeah you made the point like maybe you'd
get a better picture a better reaction
out of someone if you were being nice or
hell complimentary yeah you look nice I
like that dress with my stuff in here
right yeah I said she I heard someone
say prego I heard someone say ponytail
like talking to me and wrong yeah just
[ __ ] up yeah no the whole thing was
[ __ ] up yeah I can imagine it only
gets more [ __ ] up yeah no matter like
if you went to a different award show
would only get more and more [ __ ] up
and more and more politics it was pretty
outrageous yeah if I wasn't if I had to
do it over again I would have loved to
have skipped that that would have been
nice go right to the award show and then
leave the red car it was a stressful
thing it was but you look beautiful on
her
thank you pictures can be really [ __ ]
hot outside it was hot outside I got a
couple I guess not get a couple picture
if you did yeah my double ponytail
maiden appearance yeah ha but it was fun
he's good and then earlier on the
weekend I competed in an Olympic lifting
competition
which was a good experience overall it
was a lot uh I don't know how it was a
lot of nerves I was kind of a lot of
buildup yeah one one night we're sitting
around hanging out you streaming drunk
and fightin whatever we do and we were
talking about how we both used to be
called jack elites I played college
softball Julian played college baseball
and you know you sort of always missed
that like competition yeah even though
it's really stressful and it makes you
sort of sick sometimes cuz you're just
like dreading some some of it but ah
Julian really missed the aspect of
competition hasn't had any of it in his
adult life so after we were you
streaming and talking about that with
our Ustream friends um Julian went the
next day and just signed up for it was
like you know what [ __ ] I'm just
gonna sign up for this competition we're
gonna see what happens yeah I was and I
was happy I did it because uh when I
signed up I was like okay I have about
two months to prepare right uh and I'm
training for the record you are your own
coach no one has helped you no one has
taught you you sort of picked up the
sport Olympic weightlifting on your own
I did any information that you get to
get better I did you sort of obtained by
yourself
I did yes and it's interesting because
you know I've gotten as far as I've
gotten the sport to the point where I
can compete and actually get a medal by
myself even though the sport you know
there's there's no way around it the
sport is not cut out for you to teach
yourself having a team having a coach is
is very close to if not vital in the
sport of lightweight you'll hit a glass
ceiling we got a code which you are
about to hit soon event um about a hit
you can only get so good by yourself
yeah so yes I did I went to the gym by
myself for I'd say around 7 months
focusing on a lot the glaive the
weightlifting two months before the
competition though I signed up and then
you know I can't help but feeling like
every single day I went into the gym
even if it was just an off day or even
if I was like hurting or something I was
always focused more so than I was before
because I knew I had to be somewhere on
the 26th and I think you know just
signing up you know even the competition
aside just knowing that I had
that was really good for me because it
kept me focused like I said and it kept
me getting better even if it's just a
little bit but it was a good experience
I was really nervous I had to cut a
little bit of weight the dieting wasn't
fun yeah you were terrible the last like
couple weeks I was a little bit
miserable obviously Jen was cranky and
props the Jennifer dealing with
minecraft thank you so like cranky
hungry side but like you realize how
ridiculous that is like just like
picking up a new sport like although in
college and in high school you do a fair
amount of weightlifting to for your
training like you you sort of know what
these things are you know how to do them
yeah
it's not completely brand new to you but
that's like being like oh you know I
always really wanted to do is figure
skate so you just go to like a [ __ ]
ice rink every single day and just teach
yourself and then like Google things and
then you're just competing it's so
ridiculous for anyone that needs an
analogy of how ridiculous it is to sort
of teach yourself a sport and then go
and compete in it against people that
have been doing it for much longer than
you with real direction and coaching in
teams and then just be like yeah I just
won the bronze because [ __ ] everyone
yeah no I appreciate it was legit it was
it was cool and it was your total total
was 198 kills just let me explain the
sport really quick ok Olympic
weightlifting isn't directly correlated
to the Olympics yes Jake misconception
yeah it's all the comments on Instagram
were like oh you're so lucky to be in
the Olympics yeah there's a few of them
come on the sport is called Olympic
weightlifting it is currently the only
sport in the Olympics
that is weightlifting so that's probably
why it's called that but the sport
consists of two lifts you do each of
these lists three times you have three
attempts on each lifts and the best of
each lifts is combined and that is your
total score right
it's measured in kilograms it's also
called Olympic weightlifting to
differentiate from powerlifting yes or
no no that's 100% the name of the sport
right yeah so there's powerlifting which
is very different there's CrossFit which
is different there's uh I don't know
there's just a whole whole you know slew
of weightlifting related sports or a
strongman
but yeah so you you it's computed in
kilograms you do the clean in the jerk
which is one you do the snatch
which is the other and you add the two
up and that's your total and I got 198
kilogram total which was 121 kilos from
the snatch and 77 from sorry mixed
around 121 from the clean-and-jerk 77
from the snatch
I took bronze for me like I got through
the snatch the snatch is not my best
lift I need a lot of work on that but
after I was finished with the snatch
because I finished early I was
lightweight compared to those guys I was
really really pumped because I was like
all right this is my cleaning jerk is
coming up I was really excited because
that's what I practice so much on and it
was really if you you know if you were
to call it that my bread and butter out
of the two lifts so I got to the warm up
platforms and I was feeling good and I
feel like I really just kind of proved a
point you know people had gone out
really quick in the snatch and I feel
like I was kind of an afterthought and
then when I clean and jerked I was one
of the I was the last I was one of the
last two people yeah by the time you
started cleaning and jerking people had
already even failed their third attempt
yeah which was cool um but yeah so uh I
made all three of my cleaning jerks and
I set a personal record 121 kilograms
felt really good Jenna was right there
in the front row filming it cheering me
on it's on my Instagram which is pretty
cool I I think half of the reason why
that day was so cool was the support was
Jenna you know it was it's been a really
long road getting that competition and
it hasn't been just me like I know I've
been going to the gym alone but I'm
always the one talking to Jenna about my
thoughts on my lips and how I can
improve and she's always very receptive
and helpful she's not just like brushing
it off she was she's got a serious
interest in the sport and she supports
me and overall I couldn't say you know
there was a lot better that could have
you know went down it was a great day
and then you immediately needed some
Gatorade and I had the hydrate yeah and
then I was just like honestly I'm really
proud of you but glad I was so [ __ ]
happy after that I was like now Julianne
can eat and not be so miserable all this
yeah then we had like pizza and sushi
and Wendy's and oh my god you're so
hungry yeah you're so hungry yeah ah
bollocks
like don't take it that way julienne cut
weight correctly and smart for a long
time and then that was like the last day
you just got a little water yeah so but
like it's it makes a world of difference
when you get to eat salt and like things
like that carbs so carbs alone can just
make your mood horrible like it when
you're not eating carbs that was without
carbs for like seven straight days that
was really I know it was bad but we got
through it I did it and I will most
definitely be doing it again yeah yeah a
good weekend for us yeah it's a good
weekend better ones we're [ __ ] so
exhausted that's why we slept in today
yeah we slept interrupted we hadn't had
much sleeping sweets already so ready to
go to bed it was nice though we kind of
just powered through everything and then
we just took a load off so yeah that was
good that was good good I'm a peach I
want to talk about peach peach who's
peach tell people please why didn't that
camera I know there'll be a closes you
liked it no I'm not
uh I love you who's Pete Cheech is am
fruit but there's also my dog that is
coming to me from George I'm getting a
dog I'm getting a dog hello back sorry
okay so Jenna has a dog named Kermit
okay um that dog
Kermit is an Italian Greyhound is a very
very goofy dog and his goofiness at
first made me crazy for a long time I
was very very annoyed by Kermit and his
lack of boundaries and his goofiness and
is very needy yes Julian was like I
don't really like Kermit because he has
no boundaries but the reason why you say
that is because his mom and his sister
have a dog named puppy the only dog I've
ever known really yes she's the little
chihuahua and Pomeranian mix and she's
very well-mannered she was adopted she
you know has all the good things that
you like about having a dog - all of the
hyperactivity of having an inbred
purebred dog Kermit yes
so she's just she sits down she minds
her business she's very sweet like she's
just like a wonderful dog and then when
you met Kermit he's just like in your
face like love me like and then when
it's not and then once I love me it's
crying because
I need attention right but here's the
thing I want to put this out there is
that the neither is better or worse
puppies just all I had known so going
from that so a meeting Kermit was a
shock it was very different so at first
like I was saying it was a lot and I
really got annoyed by it especially when
he would just kind of sit at the foot of
where we were and just start crying and
because he wanted you to pet all the
crying all the all the frantic like
yelping for no reason but it's also my
fault I baby him she babies him I
believed him I work from the house and
stay home alone and he asks for all the
attention and you oblige and and that's
that's fine and that's why I adopted a
dog and not a human John you wanted to
baby him and you baby him and it's great
it's a beautiful thing so but you know
so at first I was very uh put off by
this but after spending more time and I
was with Jennifer while we grew closer
I grew closer to the dogs and I think
what uh what Kermit had to offer that
made me so nuts that that non-stop that
goofiness the goofiness is what was so
endearing it just started to turn a
little bit into something that I loved
and Kermit I could kind of see into why
he was like that a little more and he
grew to love me which I think was the
term was the determining factor that
made me really say okay I knew I hated
this dog at one point I didn't hate him
but I knew he very was very annoying and
I and he pushed my buttons to no end but
now I'm like okay he is so endearing and
he's so cute and the way he acts with me
makes me feel like okay that's so let's
go cute I've wanted a dog for a long
time and now I know which one I need to
get you know Julian was sort of waiting
for a point in his adult life where it
made sense for him to get a dog and yeah
that turned out to be around now it
turned out to be around now the running
joke was like when he was sort of had a
problem with Kermit being having no
boundaries and being just like very
needy and in-your-face I was like I said
to him casually one day when he was
talking about getting his own dog
sometimes like you could always just get
a Kermit and then you could live in your
own hell oh my god and I was true like I
would laughs it'd be like yeah that'd be
my own hell that would be my hell
and now that Israel that is going to be
my help and I couldn't be happier I'm
that's the story of Kermit though Kermit
is so [ __ ] and Dearing like so now
you see what it's like he's not even
your dog just imagine what it's like
when you get your own dog like they just
can do no wrong you don't mean yes like
I'm mad at you like why don't you do
that but I love you so much yes yes yes
yes the frantic the goofiness the
high-energy the wired miss peach uh is
gonna be my dog she's gonna be mine
peach I found peach by looking on the
website of the same breeder at bred
Kermit
so peach is actually in theory I guess
it's long loss right yeah the problem
we're all related
this is March wind IG snitch they're
Georgia Georgia based Italian Greyhound
breeder her name is Lois she's great you
know she gave us Kermit and now she's
going to give a speech on August 17th I
will go to the airport and come back
with a new dog and that will be peach
and I will share her with you
Jenna's going to shoot it we're all
going to you know share peach with the
whole internet put that on my main
channel I'm gonna put that on your
marbles yeah that I love I live for
puppies um uh so yeah just [ __ ] not
to take away from the beauty of getting
peach and Italian Greyhounds ah tell us
you took away from the beauty that's
right Beauty tell us Julian because I
got a lot of flack sometimes on the
internet from not adopting dogs from a
shelter yeah I get flack like you're
you're doing this like there's plenty of
[ __ ] dogs who need homes in here from
shelters yeah which I 100% agree with
but I was never just for me personally I
was never a dog owner previously my
family's never had dogs I did not really
know what I was getting into and I sort
of had a terrible experience with my
roommate in college who had a dog that
she got from a shelter and bit people
and was you know really really not a
nice dog although she's lovable and
sweet yes and has gotten better with age
it's I was terrified to get a dog that
wasn't ready for like I wanted to know
what I was getting myself into
yeah which is why I got very small dogs
which on the East Coast don't really
exist they go like that whereas in
fornia there's plenty of Chihuahuas and
smaller dogs available in shelters yeah
there's not really such thing as getting
a small dog in the East Coast they're
like middle sized or larger dogs which I
couldn't do because I lived in [ __ ]
little tiny teeny apartments so I wanted
to get a dog that was appropriate for my
foreseeable future in life and economic
scale that I could afford a dog um and
so I chose to get dogs from a breeder as
opposed from a shelter and I want to
know to anyone just to [ __ ] say it
because you know that it's going to be
said to you why would you choose to get
a dog from a breeder as opposed to from
a shelter well I think the aspect of
kind of the unknown and what you're
getting into when you go to a shelter I
think there's plenty of great dogs that
come out of shelters buzz came out of
the shelter my buddy Brett he just got a
dog a couple months back from a shelter
his name is buzz he's a terrier mix he's
very cute you know the the thought of
getting a dog from a shelter you know
it's a it's a do good feeling you're
rescuing a dog you're giving it a home
but for me I I think the reason why I
had such a you know a foot to gas pedal
feeling about getting a dog was the
feeling that karma gave me and there was
no surefire way to replicate that
personality or you know even just kind
of way a dog is by going to a shelter
yeah and you know maybe later in my life
if I were to get another dog or
something like that maybe it will be
right to go to a shelter but I feel like
it is I feel like that's something that
people sort of [ __ ] just glaze over
like why don't you get a shelter dog
like just of course it's admirable but
for people that have never had a dog to
just adopt like a two or three year old
dog it's a high risk it's sort of it's
sort of like gambling it's gambling it's
a good way to play especially since once
that shelter dog might seem wonderful
and once you get them home you should
have learned all of their real like
ticks yeah like ah you know [ __ ] just
for example you hear about it plenty of
times a dog maybe doesn't like certain
types of people or certain types of
shoes they hate the blinds on your
window they hate certain noises they
hate wheel
I hate kids they hate other dogs you
just never know what you're getting
yourself into and like I really wanted
to get a puppy I don't know about you
like you know what I mean yeah you can't
it's very difficult to find solutions
absolutely and it's and it's what it
like takes it like it's holier-than-thou
you should really be adopting a
childhood dog well it's like maybe your
family has had dogs your entire life and
then your 4th 5th and 6th and 7th dog
we're all shelter dogs yep those of us
that have never had dogs in their life
like you're telling me that I I'm
depriving my lifetime of having a cute
little puppy for once like [ __ ] you and
your privileged five-year-old self that
got a puppy on Christmas Day because
that never happened to me no I think I
think that the notion that you should
get an adopted dog from a shelter
because it's doing the dog or service is
very holier than that it's a it's a
selfish way to say you should do this
you anyone who ever says anything that
starts with you should in my opinion
should just shut up because you know
there's so many different things going
on well yeah because if you should get a
shelter dog well then why doesn't that
provider to have a shelter Dodger
where's your shellfish why don't you
have a shelter half of those pictures as
your shelter where's your volunteer coat
well you hit it right on the head when
you said I want to have an experience of
having a puppy I know what my you know
what dog I want I don't want to gamble
on the way my dog is I don't want to
gamble on having a dog that possibly
bites people so as much as many many
many good dogs can come out of shelters
I know what I want yeah I'm gonna go get
that it's not at a shelter my only thing
is that just from personal experiences
being a first-time dog owner with
marbles yeah I I'm just not sure that I
was ready to just go and adopt a dog do
you don't mean god no I've literally
never had a dog like people don't
understand what that means
like I I'm like figuring out as I go
with marbles like oh when they eat then
they probably need to poop after that
like geordie mean like I just have no
[ __ ] idea lights your first
experience right like oh he would
probably like to go for a walk right now
maybe that's what that means like the
best thing I ever had was a ferret which
does nothing but [ __ ] everywhere and
steal all of your things that are
robbery like that is not a dog like you
look if people don't understand like you
should get a shelter dog like Oh [ __ ]
know how to take care of a dog I want to
get a baby one so that we can grow up
and learn together yep like [ __ ] God
there's no amount of good doing that
could make me feel like I don't want to
experience a puppy growing up with me
and and I you know me like now that I
have mine and if ever I was able to buy
a house yeah where I don't have to rent
and [ __ ] be like this is how many
dogs I have yet they won't they barely
even let me have to most of them like
I'll adopt any dog because I'm ready now
because I have experience with dogs yeah
and I feel much more comfortable being
able to take on any behavioral issues
that it may come with but when I was 21
years old I was not able to take that
risk to take well to even just bring on
a dog that had even a small behavioral
issue because I wouldn't have been able
I wouldn't have any knowledge in order
to fix it yeah and I would be doing that
dog into service I'd be doing myself a
disservice and I would probably be one
of those people that wound up adopting a
dog because it's Noble and right and
then having to give it back to the
shelter because I just couldn't handle
it yeah and what good is that that's no
good that's like [ __ ] we've had
friends we know people that do this that
adopt dogs because they think that it's
good and right you adopt a [ __ ] pit
bull yeah because you think that you
know everyone has this thing against pit
bulls and then it turns out that this
not it not anything gets pit bulls in
particular but they do have a terrible
reputation and yes it's very much the
owner and not the dog but like they
adopt them in a noble good-hearted place
trying to prove everyone wrong and then
they end up giving them back to the
shelter what but really what like what
good have you done besides confuse the
dog further you've done more damage than
you done good let's not kid ourselves I
mean it's just it's it's a shot for a
lot of people but I feel like there are
plenty of people that do it just to say
that they've done it do you mean just to
say I know what you do yeah just to say
such a great person adopting these
abused dogs that no one else can handle
because I can and then your dog bites
your neighbor and now you're [ __ ] yeah
but that that's not what you want
no and peach is not gonna be like that
because coming from each is only welcome
the lovely Italian Greyhound farm in
Georgia she's gonna be my Georgia Peach
we didn't plan that
by the way Jenna came up with the name
peaches and I just chopped off that is
and that's how we thought a peach I just
thought it was really great you know I
might change it if I meet her she might
not be a peach but that's what it is for
now and yeah in just over two weeks I'm
gonna have her in my arms and I am so
[ __ ] excited every time I see Kermit
now I'm just like okay I know I'm
getting ready like I'm gonna have a mini
you who's gonna be all mine
and the thing I think I'm most excited
for is finally having a cuddle partner
because we're all good and we're all
family until we get in bed and then
everyone cuddles up with Jenna and I'm
left alone in the cold and I want a dog
to cuddle with because even if you know
if Jenna's working late on her video and
I hit and I hit the sack and I take
marbles when Jenna comes in he leaves my
arms monster time and it goes back to
this way yeah but at least mumbles goes
with you Kermit refuses to get in the
bed well and if we force him every force
him he'll wait till I'm asleep like
he'll wait til the moment I fall asleep
with I'll just get the hell out of there
jump he knows how to open the door he
does he opens the door and he doesn't
whatever he knows I open the door he's a
smart boy he's a smart boy he plays very
dumb but he's a smart boy yeah he's a
smart boy
so peach she is the newest addition
going to be the newest addition mm-hmm
to our family very excited yeah um we're
gonna have to we're gonna [ __ ] move
out of this [ __ ] apartment soon we
should talk about that my landlords a
crook
we don't want to go into too much depth
about it we're not gonna be here after
octave we're not gonna be here after
October most like just [ __ ] like most
recently what happened was it was July
4th at her
9:00 at 9 p.m. yeah we were taking
showers because we were gonna go to Las
Vegas to visit Ryan Higa and uh you know
the shower the toilet the bathtub the
sink all started overflowing with sewage
because uh we don't know why at the time
so we called an emergency plumber
instead of my landlord because we've
never called my landlord because he
doesn't do [ __ ] doesn't do anything I
shouldn't say I shouldn't say never
because when we have he hasn't done
shits what I'm saying but [ __ ] so we
called an emergency plumber he came out
and was like okay miss here's your
choice we can take the toilet off of the
[ __ ] floor and let all the sewage run
all over your house and don't worry we
can vacuum it up with a hose later or
and I'm like what's my next choice like
God and he was like we can come back
tomorrow with a scope and look in the
pipe that's going on so we were out of
towns we had to have Julian's and the
brother come and say at the house and it
[ __ ] turns out that a tree root had
grown into the pipe neighbor's a
neighbor's tree a neighbor street had
grown into the sewage pipe and so uh you
know the plumber was on the phone on the
spot with Julian's brother and they were
like should we proceed and I'm like yeah
hey just go for it and I you know I'm
not anticipating that I'm gonna get my
landlord to help me pay for this yeah
but I'm hoping that he'll be like you
know this is the right thing to do I'm
sorry and you know we'll take care of it
or pay for half of it I don't know
anything that seems reasonable long
story short he was like because you
didn't [ __ ] call me first and you did
this even though his plumber came over
and the plumber talked to the plumbers
and the [ __ ] we talked to every oh my
god whatever my landlords a crook and
he's like you know you should pay for
this because uh you didn't call me first
and I'm like all right Frank you know
what [ __ ] you and I'm just gonna [ __ ]
get out of here because that we've been
here for a while and although that was
aggravating to just just to give you an
idea I was so fed up with being
aggravated that I was sort of just like
okay Frank yep okay
and it was in the thousands of dollars
yeah it wasn't cheap and thousands of
dollars to her hair and I was so done
that I was like you know what you're not
gonna pay for it
okay I guess I'm just gonna [ __ ] move
like [ __ ] you he's pretty bad
he's a criminal he's a crook and I'm
shocked that someone hasn't taken him to
court yet yeah
shocked twenty-two of the previous
tenants have shot me out to tell me just
how bad he is I mean that says a lot
ya know is it's he's he's very very very
shitty the from from the way he acts in
person and in a way he even nothing
about any any point of his agenda is our
well-being their terrible nothing it's
all about he's always cutting corners to
take cheaper routes which always in turn
make the living experience here worse
and he's a very scummy guy he comes off
very slimy the doors don't even have
complete sealed the doors aren't sealed
so like you know cockroach like the
apartment like look looks really nice
like all Jonna has such a nice place no
it's like we're camping all the time
this is just cockroaches running
everywhere and I'd say like once a week
we spray the outside of the doors with
raid and that is the only thing that
even helps a little bit but even still
even so we have cockroaches in here
cockroaches everywhere and it's like
he's he's really bad and as much as
moving socks
I don't think Jenna or I will not my
leaving this like the car at least the
cockroach situation has gotten so bad
but we're no longer scared when you see
a cockroach yeah that's that's what Jen
said when you reach the point where you
see a cockroach and you're not freaked
out that's when of a [ __ ] possum
[ __ ] cockroach yeah so in October we
will be in a different spot hopefully
around the same area we're not sure
we're gonna we're gonna look definitely
cheaper we're definitely downgrading
though so that I can save up some money
to become my own landlord cuz I'm or it
but la is [ __ ] expensive always
expensive yeah there's a lot of
different places people think that you
know I make some ungodly amount
but it's really like we do what any
other business does which is you know
you have your company for a lot of legal
reasons for a lot of other reasons for a
lot of people that need to help you and
like you cut yourself a paycheck chin I
mean so in theory what I can afford is
what I cut myself in terms of a paycheck
all the money that's going towards you
is not going towards you correct
whether you contact Leah which a lot of
people don't understand and even if it
was like it's sort of just reckless and
because la is so expensive yeah take
every penny that you have to sort of
like invest it into something when I'm
not even completely bought like bought
into the idea of staying in LA for
forever yeah and I'm also 27 years old I
mean I don't really know a ton of 27
year olds that are buying in property in
Los Angeles alone do you own any you're
artists what am I [ __ ] like unless
they're getting a deposit from their
parents yeah you know yep so it's it's a
big decision that should not be taken
lightly I know I just kids not really
super feasible at the moment which
people are like what are you talking
about just like by foot like why don't
you invest your money you're still dumb
Nick so there's a lot of things that go
into that Sophie thank you sir for
knowing my life but [ __ ] you
but anyways will we be moving and dog
training a little bit so that I can save
some money up because this is just
[ __ ] outrageous but at least you
won't have cockroaches
well knock on wood I'm so over seeing
cockroaches it's really great yeah there
was one of my backpack the other day I
was like packing your backpack and I
reach in and oh oh what is this a little
eraser up nope it's a cockroach yeah and
there was like a flying one on the bed
we were asleep it was on the bed about a
girl asleep it flew onto the wall yeah
on the headboard and like crawling on
the head
and we jumped out and it landed on the
bed and then we [ __ ] finally caught
it but yeah if it you know disappeared
or whatever and we knew it had wings /
wanted to be on the headboard I would
not have slept in the [ __ ] bedroom
that night no I will like I'm convinced
that if you stomp around the cockroach
that it gets scared and runs the other
way which is relatively trying to work
this way and so like it ran across the
headboard and it had these giant wings
oh my god it was like this [ __ ] big
and it was like it wasn't even you black
it was like orange Oh disgusting but so
it was running across the headboard and
we're both like [ __ ] you know
grabbing anything to try and trap it but
they're better [ __ ] sneaky they can
crawl out through any tiny little yeah
they're like biggest [ __ ] but then that
crouched down and go underneath [ __ ]
yeah so we couldn't get you it went
under the carpet it would if went under
the first one in between the mattress
and I went into in the bed frame than in
the carpet so we're just like stomping
around the room until it would run
somewhere else and it did finally and
that we just like our new thing to stop
them it's just just spray it with raid
until it stops just spray that [ __ ]
into submission I don't know who I hate
more the cockroaches are Frank I think
it's a tired - except the cockroaches
are at least at least you know polite
yeah they really don't they're not like
aggressive bugs they don't want to get
in your business they're scared of
yeah it just want water and water places
to come water and food and yeah terrible
killing them but I'm sorry I can't live
with a two inch cockroach in my bed dude
I [ __ ] trapped one under a cup and I
sprayed a little bit of red in there and
I just left the cup there for like three
days I didn't even open it because I
wanted to make sure that [ __ ]
was dead soon and then I [ __ ] open it
and he was so dead and I flushed him
down the toilet but you can't stop them
don't [ __ ] leave eggs and eggs get
sprayed yeah shit's [ __ ] dude no we
basically live in just like a very nice
tent good god remember when Gina from
prank vs. prank was here and they were
crawling in from the outside door they
were crawling under it and in the house
and she there was like three about three
or four of them that one night she was
here and she just kept screaming and I
just kept
like I'm so sorry sorry it's really not
this bad but like it's pretty bad like I
thought I want to reassure you that that
wasn't a cockroach it was a cockroach
and she was like she would scream and
then she'd be like I'm really really
sorry and I'm so scared yeah I remember
that she I just can't anticipate that
you would want to come over and hang out
ever again
my sister was playing yeah my sister
playing beer pong with us the other
night yeah and she would cockroach comes
out she was like I was like oh I sorry
we have cockroach she was like I know
when I was house-sitting for watching
the dog the other week and I saw like
five and I was like oh well great you
know what's up I mean the best part is
that they stay relatively in here and in
the bedroom now that's great
but wherever these we have like these
doors that go out into the yard that's
where they get in because it's not
sealed anywhere in any way shape it's
not like if it was flooding outside we
just be flooded in here we would be
there's no ceiling there's no any sort
like under the doorframe it flooded but
you can like get down your neat hands
and knees and look under and you see the
sunlight yeah it's like you can see the
old gap so they don't really go into the
living room or in there but the in here
they just like come in here they're like
oh this is a cool place why don't just
hang on here why is it that way you
might ask Oh probably because it was
three dollars cheaper hey Frank chose
that I just go he's comin god oh my god
whatever dude he's gonna get his and
we're gonna get the [ __ ] out of here
yeah it's not my job to worry about his
Karma that's Karma's job yeah he'll get
his it'll be fine
but uh yeah I mean at some point at some
point you can you can't just use like
you're gonna stop being able to get away
with ripping the [ __ ] off of people and
in the way you act with people is gonna
come back to bite you really bad he I
believe that he ripped off that girl
that lived here before me would you she
was miserable I'm not I'm not sure I
meant Luber you speak about what
happened to her but she had a child that
lived here and some terrible terrible
things happened to her child because of
the living situation of the living
situation which were so horrific and you
know life-altering for that little girl
yeah so as much as I feel terrible at
least I don't have a child living you
that has to live with the ramifications
of this apartment for their entire life
do any mean yeah [ __ ] that's yet um
like we were saying before moving sucks
you know changing and getting up and
uprooting your life and moving somewhere
else it's hard but on accident I'm not
gonna miss this I'm not so not gonna
mess it up set will be happier somewhere
else I need men honey men I need man um
you streams going strong right now we
got the you stream going cuz we like to
have a little bit interaction book yes
are you saying yes city says rod yes um
gonna try and say in LA I mean I would I
would like to live somewhere else
eventually I think but we go for right
eye being yeah Julian works in LA and I
sort of them here for [ __ ] reasons
yeah but um in the future maybe after
this move the next one might not be in
LA we don't know but for now yeah we're
gonna look around this area you can't
say next move you don't know when the
next move is that's true you could move
every [ __ ] year forever that's true
it's a really kind of a normal thing a
lot of people move a lot the next few
years I don't know I mean I just never
know but you don't know but I'm just
saying like within the next few years
you said you don't want to live in LA
forever I know I don't want to live in a
life forever it may not be in LA where
we look within the next few years
okay fair enough fair enough
good hypo move the Scots to hot steel
Arizona it's hot there Komi currents
coming over here oh my god it's coming
right it's looking at me
is it Oh sometimes sniffing sometimes
when we're hanging out we like to
pretend like we are hiding from our
monster and he gets really really like
hiding from it like he was like the
boogeyman and weird was like hiding from
it yeah when he gets up was like oh my
God he's looking at me be like huddle
over on the couch and he's like trying
to get him he's crawling at me yeah but
if you like if you make the panic voice
yeah noises he gets very upset he feels
the need to come over and like get it
which in turn aggravates us even more
very funny very funny anyways yeah is
that it we are have we talked about a
lot of stuff I mean we hit a lot of
stuff this will keep you streaming but
is that a we at like 50 yeah we're like
50 minutes I think yeah this was a great
I think we hit a lot of stuff we kinda I
like the idea that we can recap things
in our lives you know kind of go over
especially we have big events like you
had your Wars I had my meet but don't
always have big oh we don't we you know
but I do think it was cool that we that
we recapped it and we talked about it we
answered a little bit of a little bit of
questions going on yeah we also got our
new video camera that no longer cuts out
every two and a half minutes that is why
this this podcast is brought to you by
not being interrupted thank you not
interrupting camera yes and for those of
you that would like your own not
interrupting camera visit your local
Best Buy that's all we did where no one
wants to help you exactly and don't
worry Scott Summers where there's more
customer service on the internet you can
better customer service shopping at
Amazon like the little things that pop
up that helps you more than all the
people at that spot the girl that helped
us get this camera was relatively
helpful that was the only time that's
ever only time it's ever happened I was
shocked
brought to you by the one person at that
site who can help you it's having a real
bad work um but yeah thank you guys for
watching this is fun
we will be back with our next episode
I'm talking about who the [ __ ] knows yep
that's right alright that's it for us so
that Julie Jenna and Julian podcast bye
see you next time
good wine go get some legs Gilles